good evening
good that's not how you say it good good
evening everyone
i suppose good morning or a good
afternoon or good night or whatever
depending on where you are
hello rich
i thought i'd just do a little live
stream because it's been a while since
last time it's been almost a month like
three weeks i think
so it's time to have another chat with
you guys so it's very quiet
it's probably better now right
zevi is here hello zevi
always nice to see you
hey everyone
i think i fixed the volume by now didn't
i yes good okay
hi everyone
awesome so this last time
i was
someone suggested to me that i should
put on some kind of slow chat
which i don't know how to do
but the chat seems to
be fine so far so i'll just leave it as
it is
hi nice to see everyone uh
i've just
finished my new video
today like completely
uh which is the video on sufi music
which has been a a big project i've been
working on that for i mean i'm wanting
to do that i've been wanting to do that
for a long long time
uh basically since i started the channel
and i've been working on it
for a few months now and i just finished
it today and i'm kind of exhausted to be
honest
and it should be coming out on friday
i i did a poll yesterday i think some of
you have seen it and i asked for help
regarding the name and
one of them certainly got more votes
than the other now there's a problem
there because the one that got the most
votes is the title
you know the music
of islamic mysticism
and the more i think about it the more i
realized that you know the word
mysticism
carries a lot of problems
and i kind of don't want to lead with
that uh word
although i do recognize the
that it's kind of click-baity as i said
like it will it will draw the attention
of a lot of people
um
and so what i will end up doing probably
is that i will combine the two most
popular options so
the video will probably be named
something like what is sufism and then
the sound of islamic mysticism or
something like that i think that's a
good compromise to to
not be too problematic by by leading
with the word mysticism but still
having it there to to
be appealing to a lot of people thank
you lauren's law so much for the
donation
and thank you for the kind comment i
appreciate that very much
so
sufi music
has always been one of my main fields of
interest in main fields of study
um it's kind of one of the things that
even got me into sufism to begin with
because i had i had been listening to
you know i mean sufi music is a very
broad term and
a lot of things can fit into that
category
depending on who's talking of course but
you know i listened to nusrat fatih khan
when i was growing up i listened to
uh yosun dude for example who does sing
you know has soupy themes in his lyrics
um and that kind of thing i always loved
that music
before i even knew that it was sufi
music
in particular and then when i started
studying religion and islam
and started focusing on islam
and then i found sufism and realized
that like oh i've been listening to this
stuff my whole life so that was a given
thing for me so
throughout my all my studies in religion
that's been a recurring
theme
you know i did my bachelor's
on
uh
music i guess in the muridia sufi
brotherhood in west africa not really
music ended up not being so much about
music but more so about the the
recitation of the hasadah of of ahmadu
bamba
and so that topic it has always been
with me and i've always studied that and
so i wanted to do like a really
comprehensive
good video about sufi music since i i've
i've had so much
background in studying that and so it's
going to be a long video
it's one of my longer videos it's it's
about an hour long so it's it's not
it's not as long as the even arabic
video but kind of it's it's up there
with with my longest videos
um but i'm i'm very happy with it i i'm
really excited to to for you guys to see
it too
so it's going to be both you know
going through the practical side of
sufi music in terms of the sama ritual
you know i don't want to give too much
away right now for those who are
uninitiated so to say but um
sufism has this
practice called sama which not all sufis
agree with there are some sufis have
practiced it many supers have practiced
it in history some have rejected it but
they have this thing called sama which
means listening or audition in which
music and recitation of poetry is
employed to to help the practitioner
enter sort of ecstatic states ideally
um
and and so what i will talk about is
the sort of history and practice of sama
in in the earliest periods and then
later in different sufi orders uh as
well as you know defining sufi music
more broadly i will also be diving into
more contemporary what i call art music
that employs sufi themes like you know
like i mentioned yusundur or sami yusuf
and so on
and then the second part of the video is
a theoretical part basically where i
talk about
you know theories
the philosophical positions of the
surface towards music like the role of
music and sound
from a metaphysical point of view and
psychological point of view
it's
it's going to be great
thank you to sarcastic syringe
i like that name
thank you for the donation
and thank you again for the kind comment
i i really appreciate that my content is
valuable
to to you guys it's always nice to hear
that
so yes friday a video on sufi music
coming out
finished it today
very excited
i'm gonna
try to answer some questions
again um
there are also some other very exciting
videos coming up i'll do more videos
about um
shiism
some stuff about that coming up there is
a video about the
hakim
with the pikachu also coming up
there's going to be a bit of a like
islam coming up
it's kind of a recurring theme on this
channel but it's one of those phases
right now
ulysses jonah how's your teeth doing
it's
they're doing okay i have one more root
canal treatment tomorrow
so i did one
which ended up being the first of two
which i didn't know but now i'm doing
another one tomorrow and that should be
the last one and then i'm done
so i'm very
very satisfied with that it's been a lot
i've been doing i've been going to the
dentist regularly since november and i
hate the dentist
well i kind of don't anymore because
i've gotten used to it but it's i don't
enjoy it
james smith
do you drink tea i do drink tea i drank
tea today i drank some japanese sencha
tea
i'm a bit of a tea nerd as well
i much prefer tea compared to coffee for
example
so yes i definitely drink tea
like i'm one of those people who has the
the guy wants the chinese
to brew with
and drinking little cups so people laugh
at me when i do that but
i enjoy it
oh that's great james you own a tea shop
uh of course you can send me some tea
absolutely i would
love to pay for it though
like
i would want to support your business in
that case
yes do a video ulysses do everyday in
japanese tea ceremony
yeah maybe because it's very strongly
connected to to zen buddhism
so we'll probably come i did a video um
like a year and a half ago about the
mystical origins of coffee and tea which
i talk about
the use of tea in religious practices
primarily in buddhism
those are some connections to taoism
[Music]
and i again that's another thing that
i'm doing soon is i'm i'm doing more
stuff on taoism and
t might come up there we'll see
gurgley sorry how you i'm pronouncing
that wrongly i'm sorry will there be a
video on the zaydi shia i hope so yes
but you know as many people say there
isn't a lot of stuff about this year
which also means that i don't have
access to that much stuff about this idg
either so i'm not an expert on that
topic
but
but i'm very interested in doing that i
i i i am looking forward to studying
that topic further and then
and then doing episodes on it
sikka singh
thank you so much for the kind words
so taoism yes taoism is awesome i love
doing stuff on taoism
but
the field when it comes to the academic
study of taoism there isn't a lot of
good stuff because a lot of it is kind
of new agey
questionable orientalist interpretations
the kind that will
very clearly divide between
philosophical and religious taoism and
things like that which i am not a fan of
i i have been reading a really great
book which i should remember the name of
the author but i don't but it's called
the taoist tradition which is basically
like a course literature book it's very
much like a book you would have as
course literature if you do a course on
taoism but it's really good i i
felt like a relief when i was reading
that that's finally someone who's
tackling this topic from
from
a
perspective that feels scholarly
that's that's his name stefan thank you
so much louis come jeffy
great stuff
i shake have you explored well first of
all thank you so much for the content
thank you for the for the compliments
have you ever explored the modern occult
movement i have but not to any major
degree i'm much more
um
i know much more about
you know earlier occultism i'm similar
to to justin in that sense
the modern
world of occultism is not my
field of expertise i have a friend
called pal fox neld here in sweden
who has who is doing who's an expert in
that stuff and he's doing amazing work
he wrote a book became quite famous
called
satanic feminism
which is just a fascinating book
but it's not
not my field of expertise yet
ackel senpai why not the traditional
books of taoism
for example transfer i did a full video
on drums
about a year ago
i'm very happy with that video probably
one of my favorites
i love the drawn so the glances one of
my favorite pieces of literature in
history i think it yeah
just amazingly funny amazingly
profound uh difficult in the best kind
of way
i love books the best kind of books are
the freedom and you
the first time
you don't understand a single word
and then you read it again and you're
like oh
maybe
and then it starts to dawn and you like
i love that stuff
there's a great translation of the drawn
seb by
brook saporin who also
uh it's called drawn to the essential
writings
and it includes commentaries by later uh
by later commentators both
mostly like buddhist commentators who
will have like a buddhist perspective on
on the text
i forgot what i was saying drunza right
i became um
distracted by zevi's question about
militia eliade
who
[Music]
i have a complicated relationship with i
guess
because every i haven't read much of his
works and i'm not that familiar with it
but i i studied it when we when we
studied comparative religion he was one
of the like
main theoreticians theorists whatever
um
and every time i read him i kind of
liked his style in a way but
in the contemporary study religions
there's a kind of
people don't like him he's like outdated
they say
so i've been fed that perspective like
he's fascinating but you know
we've moved past him but then when i
read him you know i kind of like what
i've heard so i don't know i i don't
feel informed enough to to have an
opinion on him
but i'm intrigued by him to say the
least
aditya hey philip did you check out the
ramanuja statue yes
actually last time i did a live stream
a person in the chat
whose name escapes me
um sends or told me about that and i
looked it up
no wait that wasn't in live stream that
was in a chat anyway i saw that statue
and it's huge
it's it's yeah i showed my wife and she
was also amazed
uh
looks beautiful
i love that he gets he's getting that
kind of attention because i love
ramanuja i think he's
a really fascinating figure
philip george how do you pronounce your
name
also in swedish you pronounce it philip
philip holm
so if you want to be
swedish about it then that's how you
pronounce it you can say philip
people have called me philippe
which i don't
i don't oppose to it
but yeah you can call me philip
it's a greek name
originally i've been i've been told it's
a greek name
that means friend of horses which when i
was a kid i thought was lame
but now i kind of love it
thank you george or georg
for the donation
um your channel is helping a lot with
the research you're writing a book
that's very exciting
what are you writing your book about i
would love to know and i am
honored to have
helped
with creativity that makes me very happy
so zev you asked me about minshi eliader
what are your thoughts on michiarliada
please tell me and suggest to me
books to read about
do him like metal
yes and no i used to be a metal head
basically when i was a teenager i
listened to
all this stuff you know thrash metal
like metallica and and you know slayer
and that stuff
um system of a down and then through
that moved beyond that and then i kind
of left that stuff behind and now i kind
of can't stand some of that stuff
like i don't listen to metallica i'd
like but you know sometimes i hear
there's good metal out there too
i like all kinds of genres
but there's something about
certain kinds of metal that i can't
stand right now probably because i have
a back and i have a history with it and
i kind of
associate that with a version of myself
that i'm
have moved past
but
yeah
i i don't i don't dislike metal
do you like sabaton i never got into
sabaton
it was too like it's too uh
it always felt too
i don't know how to put it into words it
just felt
a little too theatrical to me like i
always been much more like dark and into
the like raw stuff
tunisia
i am swedish yes and do i play minecraft
i basically never played minecraft
i mean i do play video games not as much
as i used to of course
because you know being an adult
gets in the way sometimes
but uh minecraft never
became a thing for me
i work at at a school and a lot of the
so i work with kids that are basically
11
12 and a lot of them play minecraft
and roblox
i think fortnite has kind of
fizzled out a bit
it seems it seems to me that roblox is
the new thing i've never touched that
game either but
a lot of talks
here again i'm curious if you're thank
you for the donation by the way i'm
curious if you're familiar with the
works of bernadette roberts i don't
think so
she's one of the most clearest book
contemplatives of our times no i should
look her up then i don't think i've ever
heard that name actually
oh no so i my comments on minecraft uh
i i'm by no means saying that it's only
a game that kids play of course not
i'm just saying that many of the kids
that i work with do play that game
but that's a game that
you know
as far as i understand it's a game that
can be played by by all kinds of ages i
know many
adult friends who play minecraft as well
so my comments had
nothing to do with that
at least i would probably at some point
tackle the question of the difference
between what would
a difference
that i don't i agree with william chidik
and that perhaps
there isn't much of one
in terms of a difference at least if we
read you know
from the perspective i've been arabi
he seems to say very similar things to
what what
supposed to be saying
you know of course a lot of i believe
later followers would express what would
in more you know radical ways
it's a it's a fascinating
topic though so i will probably yes i've
been i've been thinking about doing a
video that um tackles that the
difference between those two for a while
it probably happened at some point
mustafa
[Music]
eva brown's new jewish husband what do
you think of norse mythology i'm
fascinated by north mythology
and
[Music]
i've been watching jackson crawford for
a while
who is a wonderful youtuber who
specializes in
ancient norse essentially and on you
know things like norse mythology too if
you haven't seen jackson crawford that's
his name right jack
yes
you should definitely check out that
channel
i
don't know nearly as much about norse
mythology as as he does even though i am
from a nordic country
i have the poetic edda in swedish
translation
but i but uh you know
i should know more i want to know more
about that stuff
there's a there's a
there's a kind of documentary on the
channel about
contemporary norse practitioners in
sweden
it was one of the first videos i
uploaded i think
junk
junk dj
hi what do you think about tsuhu
practices where they call mohails angels
and jinns by doing some type of zika is
this real i have never heard of such a
practice
i mean that sounds the kind of thing
that that people who don't like sufis
would
claim
that i've never heard sufis talk about
it like they are
calling jinns that that's uh that would
belong to a different
now you know then we're in the territory
of you know sorcery or
you know magical practices which sufis
have have you know
partakening occasionally but um not in
terms like the good or as a you know
sufi practice as we know it
uh
skeptzig what do you think of atheism
i don't think much about atheism
um
i know it's one way to look at the world
along with many other ways to look at
the world i think it's uh
you know being an agnostic is a you know
which isn't the same as an atheist but i
think
it's it's a reasonable
conclusion about the world it's not
necessarily one that i hold
but
there are definitely good arguments for
atheism
most of the arguments for atheism that
are put forth
by
atheists publicly or you know public you
know
public figures or not are usually not
very good arguments but there are very
good arguments
it's going to scroll up because i saw
names name thank you so much
uh
a donation from my
norwegian
brother or sister
thank you so much
and bobby thank you also for your
donation
terrible truth beautiful lies do you
like sausage then
i don't eat sausage because because i
you know i don't really eat meat
i don't call myself a vegetarian because
i sometimes eat meats i do the buddhist
thing where i eat meat if someone offers
me meats or if i like i go to someone
and they have cooked
a meal with
meat in it i'll eat it but
generally i
eat you know
eat a vegetarian diet so i don't use it
but but i
when i used to eat meats i did like
sausage yes
how many languages do you speak
i
well swedish english
a little bit of arabic
i studied spanish in
school
between like sixth to
ninth grade
and i don't remember anything
i can
say hola and buenos dias and those kinds
of things
but i don't remember that so
english and swedish i guess and just
very limited amount of arabic
ulysses do swedish norwegians and deins
understand each other generally yes
swedes are worse at understanding into
norwegians than they are at
understanding us i don't know why
because we
feel like we're better than them or
something i don't know but um
norwegian is easier to understand
danish harder
but if if they speak slowly then then
yes
usually yes
eric
vertheler
v vera teller 92 thank you for the
donation
question what do you think behemoth and
leviathan are in the book of job and do
you believe in evolution
do you interpret the book of genesis
literally what i think well first of all
when i think behemoth and leviathan i
think they're mythical creatures that
ended up in the bible they're probably
creatures that um
people in the region
know well it was part of the belief of
people in the region and it made there
made its way into the book
that the people in that region
composed
um
do i believe in evolution
yes i well i think that
in general the theory of evolution is a
very good theory for the evolution of
species
on earth so i generally describe to that
theory and do i interpret the book of
genesis literally no no
i wouldn't say so
let's see if i have missed anything
could i say some sentences in arabic
because yours is good thank you i don't
know why because now
i'm getting nervous because you're
asking me to speak arabic when i don't
really know how to speak arabic
i don't know what i would say you know
salaam alaikum where i could say
i could recite uh
poetry by ibn arabi adena
[Music]
because i memorized that poem
um
thoughts on the movement meets somewhere
i love it
very disturbing very dark
very
yeah i
and i very much enjoy that
no worries evie
do you think ancient egyptian had an
influence on christianity for example in
the idea of a trinity in life after
death
life after death maybe
we'll have to go way back to like you
know some of the uh
greek philosophers will state that you
know the idea of the soul surviving
after death comes from the egyptians
originally i don't know
if you know if that's true i'm sure
other cultures have had similar ideas
too
um
the other year the trinity i think would
if we're going to trace it to some kind
of intellectual tradition it would more
go
i think into you know theories within
platonism for example which
you know around the time of christianity
actually started to
well had to start talk about
reality in terms of you know a monad and
dyad and the relationship between those
three as being an essential component of
reality for example i think
there's some interesting stuff there
the number three returns a lot in those
kinds of philosophical traditions
right around the time that christianity
starts to develop i'm not sure there is
necessarily a correlation
but there definitely could be
terrible truth beautiful lies he only
knows what he's reading yeah i guess so
and i guess also what i've
been told
at least in terms of conceptual
knowledge i mean that all comes from
reading from
studying with other people and so on
then you could argue for the kind of
surabalyan thing of or the sufi thing of
there being a you know a direct kind of
intuitive knowledge as well i'm not
claiming to have that kind of knowledge
but
i don't know what what other kind of
knowledge i would have or where my my my
knowledge would come from if not from
other
places you seem to
to want me to to get some knowledge from
magic mushrooms
who's to say i haven't
[Music]
how are you i'm doing fine i'm tired
like i said in the beginning of the
video or the live stream i've been
working really hard on this sufi music
video
so
i'm a bit tired
uh
but other than that i'm doing just fine
how are you doing
it's really nice when i you know you
start to notice people
i mean i most of you guys i've seen
before you know i've seen some of your
people in the comments for
some of you for years have been there
and i really appreciate you guys
the fact you're still here a lot of you
how did you get interested in studying
religions
i can't pinpoint a reason because i feel
like i've always been interested in that
kind of thing everyone's been very
inquisitive i've been very
you know
absorbed in
questions and thoughts
and you know religion religions
have a lot of questions and a lot of
thoughts
and i've always just been fascinated by
things like mythology
and you know the
you know the history of religions and
then the origins of different religions
and you know it's always something
that's really fascinated me
for as long as i can remember basically
um i didn't know i was going to study it
or that was
going to become such a main a big part
of my life until i
took a course in religious studies
as part of a larger sort of education i
did
i've told you this before but i started
international relations originally and
then i took a course in religion and
that just kind of stuck
[Music]
i
do i really look that tired
is it true there is no heaven or hell in
judaism
well it's a complicated topic in the old
testament there is no heaven or hell
right so in the old testament they talk
about this thing called the sheol
uh which is just this kind of hades-like
place that everyone goes to
and it seems like the idea of heaven and
hell
uh comes into judaism through
apocalypticism around the turn of the
first millennium
that's one theory
and then made its way into christianity
and so on from there
but then of course it has also become a
part of some
strands of judaism
so and there are other people i think if
sevi is still in the chat i'm sure he
has
much more to say on that and he knows a
lot more about it than i do but
in terms of the old testament
they have this thing called sheol and
there's no direct reference to anything
resembling heaven and hell in the way
that we think of it
someone has something about swedish folk
music i'm trying to find that question
again because that was interesting uh
well the question was if i liked there
it is
uh al balism
allah ballism i don't know how i
pronounced that but do you enjoy swedish
folk music i'm a stockholm based fork
musician come jam i would love to come
chat
i'm also based in stockholm
uh i know there's been some jams in
gamlaston
uh with like medivh like medieval faulk
music jams
which i've been meaning to go to but i
haven't
i don't suppose you've met morton hilbum
he's a good friend of mine he also plays
a lot of folk music
plays he has two groups one called ux v
and another called tail coat
and they do really amazing work
he's an amazing percussionist
and tonys k have ever studied greek
mythology when we studied greek
mythology in school
uh
and that's not the extent of my study in
greek mythology but
we all that's part of the the sort of
curriculum to learn about greek and and
norse mythology and that kind of thing
um
so i've studied it i've you know
as an adult i've more studied greek
philosophy
more so than
mythology
so my my knowledge on that is is limited
also compared to other mythologies like
egyptian and so on but
i have to have the basic i have the
basics down william gunderson thank you
for the donation
would you please consider doing a video
on the epic
free will debate between luther and
erasmus
yeah sure
sure that sounds like a really
interesting thing which i would have to
read up more about but
i will definitely write that down
[Music]
anik
brother holm
you should start a series where you read
from different classical texts similar
to the reading you did from 1001 nights
a lot of people have actually requested
me to do more videos like
that um and if if there is a
if there are people who want me to do
that then i am happy to do that i i used
to do a lot more
videos like shorter videos
that one was an hour long but short like
i would read sections from works so i
did one where i read the
you know the great hymn to the arten i
have one where i read the song of the
read by rumi
and i haven't done one of those in a
while
but maybe it's time i revive that
series
perhaps and maybe i can do longer videos
like the one for a thousand and one
nights there is a copyright there are
copyright questions about that because
you're using a particular translation
that has a you know but
i think we can
make that work
you should you should read gilgamesh i
would love that
hmm
that's a long one though that's gonna
take
it's gonna be a serious
cozy
reading gilgamesh with philip every
saturday night
sounds kind of nice actually
we'll see what what what we'll do that's
a that's a
if not reading the whole gilgamesh then
certainly parts of it or doing videos on
it in some shape or form
absolutely
are you a full-time youtuber
no i mean i have it i have another job
but in terms of
the hours i put into it
i'm kind of a full-time youtuber too
although as i said last time i've in the
last few months i've been more careful
to take breaks and not overwork myself
i don't i don't know if i could be a
full-time youtuber because i i would go
crazy
just sitting by myself
working i love writing and i love
editing most of the time
but if that was all i did then i would
just that would that wouldn't be good i
think i need
uh
you know like for working at us at a
school as i am right now that's such a
dynamic environment
and there's a lot of energy which is
energy consuming but it's also it also
gives you a lot of energy
i think it's a really nice balance for
me to sit here you know when i'm at home
and thinking about and writing about all
these
just
really complicated philosophical
existential questions
and histories of religion and then
during the day
the complete opposite
m mccarry what is the first what is the
world's first religion in academic
consideration
it's it's i think that's basically
impossible to say you used to be this
idea that the first religion or the
first kind of religion was animism
and then you know that developed into
polytheism and then that became
monotheism and then so and and then but
that's based on a kind of
teleological worldview
where
you know we're living in the most
enlightened age and everything prior to
this has been just a gradual
evolution from primitiveness to
enlightenment and that's a very
old-fashioned
way to look at that that's not really
accepted by the majority of
of
[Music]
so i'm going to have to block this
person obviously i don't how to do that
um
there you go
uh what was i saying
i forget
is the volume still low
okay so see i wish
there needs to be a better way add
moderator
oh no
this is a mess
let's see if i can
solve this
so see i wish
can i make you a moderator
i'm sure you
you're better at this stuff than i am
sorry about this guys
i'll try to ignore it for now and see if
if
we can solve it in some way
keep asking questions
i'm sure there's a way to ban them but i
don't know really how to do it that's
why i gave uh
sean which the right to moderate the
chat see maybe he knows how to do that
stuff better than i
hmm
let's see there were some questions back
here um
yet a good question how did you connect
to the sufi order in sweden
there are plenty of sufi orders in
sweden
um
and i've been in contact with a few
different ones i've
hung out with the modula in sweden and
the tijaniya
[Music]
as well as the
well there's a group that's sort of
loosely connected to chishti as well
well studying religion
you kind of end up with those kinds of
contacts i guess
um you know you know people who know
people
they're not they're not exactly
you know hidden uh
let's see
i saw
moist about have you read about sheikh
al-murfield yes
i was actually reading a book about
sheikh al-murfi today
because i'm preparing to do some videos
on 12versism or a video
probably more videos on twilight sheism
so i've been reading up on sheikh murphy
than some of the the main
intellectuals from that tradition
thank you robert benson for the
donation any more kabbalah content in
the future definitely
definitely there is a
exciting collaboration coming up that's
sort of kabbalah related at least
jewish mysticism related
also you do know morten awesome
you studied at kmh at the same time was
studying composition was doing folk
music yes i've been there i was there he
had his little room in at guam hall
and he we we
rehearsed because we're doing a
recording together called it's actually
on youtube it's called it's on my zini
channel
uh this song is called and it's me and
morten and a guy called
nasiri
who plays the tanbur and i play the ud
and i sing
and we would do our rehearsals for that
recording at guam hall
is sufi music the same as shia music not
really
i mean the
sufism and
shiism is a
the majority of sufis
or sunni you could say but there are
shia sufis as well as we've seen in my
video on the nimatellahi order for
example
usually in shiism
um what what is you know the equivalent
of sufism is known as er fan
which could be translated something like
gnosticism
which a lot of the time would reject a
lot of the practical aspects of that
tradition so you know like for example
sama or music
or
maybe even vicar and uh
things like that
while
maintaining the
intellectual sides of of sufism like ibn
arabi's
ideas
which became very influential for
thinkers like mulasadra
who represents that tradition of erfan
rather than you know sufism
so i would say
it's a difficult question to answer but
i would say yes there's there's a
difference because sushi music is
aimed with a particular sort of it has a
practical use in the sense that it's
used to to reach
a station closer to god or to to help
the practitioner on the path the
spiritual path whereas in shia music you
have shia music that essentially you
know is praise hymns or praise songs for
the imams like hussein and adi and so on
which is this does not have the same
practical function
that would be the main difference
have you ever experienced a metaphysical
situation like seeing ufo or something
no
i haven't
and i'm sad about it because i would
love to see a ufo
what time is it 9 30 okay
should
should be uh wrapping up pretty soon
because i should probably get some sleep
before i go to work tomorrow
but let's i'm gonna stay here for a
little while more
[Music]
harman singh thanks for the seek video
thank you very much
judging by your last name seeing i
assume you're sick
which means
[Music]
i'm especially happy when people from
the religious tradition i cover
appreciate the episodes
that's sort of an extra seal of approval
that i am always very happy with so
thank you
ingrid are you late you're a bit late
yes
i mean
can you be late for this kind of thing
it's still live
but we've been going for what
hour and a half no
not even an hour 51 minutes okay
so
idk idk your thoughts on coptic orthodox
christianity like these questions are
difficult because
what else can i say then that
i think it's fascinating i love it i
think it's really interesting
um
i've never been to a coptic church
i've been to so i wasn't saint
petersburg back in 2017
in a sort of an eastern orthodox church
which was one of the most amazing
experiences i've ever had in terms of
like
religious tourism or whatever you want
to call it
just being there for the liturgy
and hearing the the choir sing
was really really
touching
that's something that will always stay
with me and then i also the same day
went to an armenian
orthodox church but never a coptic
church
i've never been to egypt so when i go to
egypt i will definitely want to do some
of that
x j w messianic
thank you for the donation
can you at some point do a video
regarding messianic judaism
absolutely
noted
i will
keep that in mind
[Music]
thank you also for the donation would
you be interested in a video on early
arabic cosmology
how early are we talking we're talking
early islamic or pre-islamic
and
you know
the answer to both questions is yes
but there's only so much time
[Music]
it's not something that i prior you know
prioritizing right now but definitely
i would i would eventually get to every
conceivable topic if i had all the time
in the world but you know hopefully i'll
get there eventually
so pre-islamic okay yeah absolutely
we did i did one video on pre-islamic
religion
which was kind of just covering the
basics because after all we don't know
all that much uh you know with the
with the research of people like ahmed
al-jalad we're getting more and more
information
so i'm looking forward to to to you know
all the discoveries that are going to be
made up about pre-islamic arabia and the
religious and
you know intellectual traditions that
existed there and once that information
comes out
i'll definitely want to do some episodes
on that
siawish asks if i want to collaborate on
a video about early muslim dogma
what muslims believe before abdul malik
so your muslims in quotation marks
suggest to me that
this is related to you know theories
like
donors
believers movement theory
uh which i've been very fat i think
that's a very interesting perspective
so i'm definitely open to doing that
you you know
you can hit me up on
this corner whatever we can talk more
aaron ball thank you
for the donation
mr matrix are you going to make a
discord server there is a discord server
but it's only for my patrons
for now
do you think that all religions are from
the same source
and they diverged or changed from each
other with time
no
not in terms of like a history
historical view of religion
you know if you mean like it comes from
the same source as and it comes from the
same you know human
uh tendency or from the same
psychological or you know
perhaps you know even spiritual
source the same tendency within the
human soul to to seek those kinds of
answers and more i'm definitely more
open to that kind of perspective but in
terms of having like the an actual
same source
uh
from a historical perspective no
it seems that all not all religions but
it seems religions come from all kinds
of
directions in human history
what sort of thing upsets you about
seeing
upsets you seeing the way the west
covers islam
all kinds of things it's just really
simplified it's um
often based on orientalist
assumptions or on uh
you know skewed
perspectives and you know islam is
portrayed as
inherently fundamentalistic in a
negative sense right or you know violent
and so on
which
is you know of course
not the whole story
and that's one of the reasons
i've focused so much on islam is and
then why i do this kind of content is to
counter those kinds of
awful
portrayals of not just islam but all
kinds of religions but islam has of
course
had an especially bad time in terms of
coverage
in the west in the last few decades
where do you draw the line zara
where do you draw the line between islam
and islamism so the sort of technical
definition of islamism
would be you know
the idea that islam
should dictate
politics essentially
and i i tend to go with that kind of
definition
a lot of people look at islamism as
islamic
as synonymous with
terrorism or extremism
which
is also
problematic right because majority of
islamism
is
not like that it's simply a perspective
where you know muslims think islam
should play a major role in political
uh life
or as part of the political system
essentially
in the lab why
islam so violent and followers so full
of hates i wouldn't say that that's true
there are violent muslims
there are muslims who are hateful
but i
would be a huge mistake to think that
islam in itself
is hateful or violent because religions
aren't violent or hateful
it is people who are hateful and violent
and
to view muslims in particular as hateful
or violent is not only inaccurate
but in the cases where there may be
muslims who are violent or or frustrated
also comes from political and social
circumstances in the middle east today
and for the last couple hundred years
for example colonialism you know when
you start to look at that kind of
history you start to
realize where a lot of those
frustrations and frustrations come from
without necessarily agreeing with
you know we don't have to agree with the
conclusions of those people you can
definitely understand where that kind of
frustration comes from right so i would
be very careful with
you know conflating
that as a result of the religion itself
you know
and on top of that to say that to say
that kind of thing is inaccurate to
begin with also
now there's a lot of questions right now
and it's going by really fast and my
eyes and brain is really tired right now
i'm trying to i'm trying to keep up
so sorry if i'm i'm
i miss a lot of your questions
angeles here
thank you for coming angela
very glad to see you
thank you for our last collaboration
that was wonderful i always enjoy
working with you and look forward to
working with you again
everyone here should definitely check
out angela symposium
she is an expert on you know
all things
occult
things like shamanism and you know she's
a great scholar and has a has a youtube
channel called angela symposium you
should check out if you're into that
kind of
content
tunistic is using
google translate
thank you for calling me cool
that was actually quite a
quite intelligible sentence in swedish
google translate has become a lot better
over the years i've noticed
muhammad cameron if you had two options
what would you study more philosophy or
science and why
i would
you know i would go to
i would go back
to a previous definition of science as
simply a you know as the same thing as
philosophy and you know get two flies
with one stone is that how you say two
birds with one stone
uh
that's a different question
it's a very difficult question um i mean
i guess i have chosen philosophy more so
than science
but i don't really
separate them all that much
probably because i spent so much time
with old medieval philosophers and they
didn't
see much of a or make that clear of a
distinction
but i think the two fields can
definitely
contribute
and help each other out i think it's
unhelpful to to separate them too much
but there's also definitely something to
be said for science as a method
and have a very sort of positivistic
view on that
in some regards at least
but that can then be informed by
you know philosophical speculation i
don't know
i'm ranting i'm just babbling
a swedish question wilkin exam harder
so what i guess what degree do i have i
have a master's degree in religious
studies and i have a bachelor's degree
in international relations so i don't
have fancy phds like a lot of my
colleagues here on youtube
but i have a master's degree
if i
second question if i didn't have my
youtube channel how would you make money
well i do make money from another job i
work as a teacher as an english teacher
at a school
maybe through yeah i'm also a musician i
would maybe do some music
you know money is never the you know the
the
what do you how do you say it it's it's
not the uh
the reason i do any of these things
it's a it's a nice bonus though
and it helps
to continue doing these things
uh you know
my patrons who i'm
eternally indebted to and so grateful
for everyone who
who who donates and so on
that definitely helps uh in terms of
getting material you know books and and
you know updating the equipment so that
i can make better videos and so on so
of course money is a factor that's very
important or
not maybe not important but it helps in
a lot of ways but it's never been uh the
reason
i've done any any of these things that's
a very sort of
it's a cliche to say but
in this case it's true
and he collabs with religion for
breakfast yes
we without saying too much yes i we have
some stuff that we
want to do but it's not happening
in the coming weeks at least it's
a little ways off but i will definitely
be working with andrew moore
[Music]
do your students perceive your beard as
other religion
looks as increasing religious
nationalism polarization of scandinavia
too i don't quite get your
question maybe you could formulate that
a bit differently
my students
perceive my beard they they
tend to like my beard they
they sometimes tell me i should
trim it a bit more
which is you know fair enough i don't
really take as much care of it as i
should
but
[Music]
they told me i should color my beard or
dye my beard
purple
which i'm not going to do
but
they enjoy
the beard
muhammad anik again brother holm during
your research on sufi music have you
come across the music of no surat fatih
khan and other pakistani musicians
yes as i said in the beginning of the
live stream
thank you sidi and
kahi or kaishi again for the donation
thank you very much i appreciate all all
the support uh nusrat yes so as i said
at the beginning of live stream um i've
been listening to nusrat since before i
knew what sufism was you know i've been
listening to nusa fatalikan since i was
a kid
and so i didn't have to
discover him through any research
because i've always known him and i've
always been a huge fan of him
and he's going to show up in the sufi
music video
travis
chambray cambrie chambray why did jesus
say i came not to bring peace but a
sword that's
that's a yeah that's the question right
jesus was quite the uh
the radical guy i think
um not necessarily that he he meant that
in a violent way you know you can you
should ask you know a christian
theologian to answer that question
there are various interpretations of
what that means
but i've always seen jesus as quite a
quite a sort of a radical figure
you know the love
that he emphasizes right
it's not your kind of
coffee drinking
being nice to people love like the love
that jesus teaches
uh and the love of the new testament
that christianity has at its base it's a
radical kind of love right it's it's a
it's an extreme
love
uh and so even in that sense it's kind
of
you know his teachings are radical and
so i think that kind of
quotes is not surprising
i don't know i don't i can't give you an
interpretation because i'm not a
christian theologian and i know i
i'm not i'm not
how do you say i'm not
authorized
to give an interpretation
so first of all midi 510 thank you very
much for the donation do you have an
interest in the frameworks for
understanding god
and the relationships between god and
humanity using modern language and
context
so how do you mean
so what's a modern language and what's
what's modern languages and context in
this case
um you mean like in terms of
sort of scientific
theoretical language
um
there's a great
i don't remember who it was but there
was a
comic
or a comedian sorry a comedian who said
something like
to look for god
using science
is like searching for your car keys
using google
which which i thought was well kind of
funny but also a
bit profound as well
uh in that you know
it's kind of a useless thing to use
scientific tools to to discover
something like that that's that's a
completely other
um
thing
maybe rephrase i don't quite i just
started
improvising it because i didn't fully
understand what you meant i think
i saw a good question here
tim why do you think what do you think
is the main reason icons are prohibited
in islam
it seems pretty clear to me that
well first of all
well icons i guess
is
kind of always
prohibited in islam in terms of icons as
you know
figures of of devotion right
uh not to say that
depictions of humans and animals are
universally privileged islam there have
been many who have
had help different opinions different
schools that have different opinions on
that and so on but i think the reason
why there is a general uh controversy
around images and and and so on in islam
is because islam originates in an
environment where it stands in complete
opposition
to the
you know pagan
religions in arabia at the time of the
life of the prophet muhammad and so it
would it's obvious
it's an obvious thing for this new
community of muhammad's to
try to
take as much of a you know to put as
much distance between themselves and the
practices of the pre-islamic arabs as as
possible and that includes you know this
complete
eradication of all kinds of of
idolatry right and any kind of
uh
devotion and worship of images
and so it seems very clear to me that
that's where that comes from that
there's always this unease about
images of whether of humans or animals
because that's a kind of a
to some it gets too close to the kind of
polytheistic practices
where it can lead to that
thank you n for the donation sufi
resources in svadiya in sweden i see
only sunni shia resources as in like
people
there's a book
by my old supervisor called sufism in
sweden or sufismisvaria
which sort of goes through all the
different suvi orders
and you know where they are located and
who's the leaders and so on so and it's
it's published by the uh
what's it called
some
i don't remember but it's called sufis
fabia you should check that out if
you're interested in
knowing more about the different sufi
organizations in sweden
i i'm thinking i should start wrapping
up because it's
it's 10
10 o'clock overs or 10 p.m
and i need to start thinking about
getting some sleep
but
thank you all so much for showing up for
asking your questions for for donating
for being here i never got to hear
zevi's answer to the michielia the
question
maybe next time
but yeah thank you so much look forward
to to the video on sufi music it's
coming out on friday
don't know what time on friday but it's
it's coming out it's
you know for those who weren't here in
the beginning it's a long one it's going
to be an hour long
it's one of my most ambitious videos
it's going to cover all
the bases you know the practical side of
the theoretical side
and it's going to be really good
i'm very proud of it so far well it's
done and i'm proud of it right now i'm
sure i'll find things
that i want to change as you know two
seconds after i release it but um i'm
very happy with how it turned out and i
hope you're going to like it to very
much look forward to seeing
what you think
because it's one of my
favorite topics you know it's a topic
that's that's been part of my
academic
career from the beginning it's always
been one of my main
things is music and religion and music
in sufism in particular
so
good night everyone
if you like me
are going to sleep soon and uh yeah i'll
do another live stream like this soon
enough um but before then i hope to see
you perhaps in a sort of premiere live
chat on friday if we do a premiere or at
least in the comments on that next video
thanks so much
bye bye